si un vendedor de materias primas les
dice que se encuentra el mercado
invertido lo que en esencia está
diciendo es que cuesta más comparar a
algo alguna materia prima ahora ahora
cuesta más es más caro de lo que cuesta
comprar un contrato futuro de esa misma
materia prima cualquiera que ésta sea
así que después es más barata menos caro
la pregunta que ustedes podrían hacer o
que el vendedor podría preguntarse a sí
mismo es
si esta es una situación alcista
alcista y no hay una regla obvia kings
para el sentido como nos dice que si
alguien les dice que algo cuesta más
ahora que comprar lo más barato en el
futuro en el mercado hay una situación
de desesperación la gente está
desesperada porque si no estuvieran
desesperados lo racional por hacer sería
esperar un poquito más para obtener lo
más barato en el futuro si no
necesitáramos de ese maíz o de ese oro o
de ese petróleo en este instante podemos
decir bueno puedo adquirir un contrato
futuro para que se me entregue ese maíz
o ese oro o ese petróleo en el futuro
por un precio más barato y ni siquiera
tendría yo que almacenarlo durante todo
este tiempo así que si las personas
fueran racionales y no estuvieran
desesperadas esto no ocurriría pero
debido a que están dispuestos a hacer
esto a pagar más ahora que pagar menos
en el futuro nos muestra que es posible
que haya algún tipo de escasez
en el caso del petróleo quizás la
entrega del petróleo se ha visto
reducida o destruida o si es maíz a lo
mejor se han perdido cosechas y las
personas necesitan comerlo pero por
ejemplo para materias primas que no son
usadas como el oro por ejemplo si vemos
mercado inverso en el oro yo no diría
que se debe a la desesperación cuando el
oro entra en un mercado inverso es por
una necesidad irracional de tener el oro
en este momento en lugar de esperar un
poco más y tenerlo en el futuro más
barato puede indicar que la sociedad
está a punto de colapsar y que la
entrega futura del oro puede no
realizarse quién sabe qué es lo que
puede pasar así que en general cuando la
gente habla de mercados invertidos es
causada por esta desesperación en el
mercado y la gente tiende a percibirlo
como una situación alcista ya que si la
gente está desesperada hay demanda por
esto mi argumento es que ustedes no
pueden ver sólo un aspecto de algo
multifacético y poder decidir si es una
situación alcista
lo que sí pueden decir es que está
ocurriendo algo anormal en el mercado
debido a cierto tipo de desesperación
que podría ser ocasionada por algún tipo
de escasez o por algo muy racional como
el querer poner las manos sobre algo en
este momento porque francamente si
ustedes quieren comprar oro simplemente
por querer invertir en él no lo van a
comer no lo van a usar para que funcione
su auto o nada parecido sería mucho más
racional y de hecho si ustedes ya
poseyeran algo de oro en este tipo de
mercado en el que tenemos un mercado
inverso lo racional sería vender
ahorita el oro que se tiene y comprar un
contrato para volver a comprar ese oro
en el futuro donde es más barato y de
esta manera tener una ganancia libre de
riesgos